Film Courage: How do you direct a great scene?
What are you looking for?
What has to happen?
Frank Coraci, Writer/Director: How do I direct
a great scene?
That’s not a fair question [laughs].
You’ve got to direct a scene as best you
can and then sometimes there are moments where
you’re like wow this could be the best scene
in the movie.
You just try to service the story the best
you can.
So some movies I feel like you want the hand
of the director to push it around and push
the camera and move the camera and other movies
like a romantic comedy like THE WEDDING SINGER
I wanted to just step back and not feel the
director’s hand so on that movie I used
colors to tell the story.
Adam goes from when he’s happy to blue.
When he gets his heart broken he camera dollies
and you see red brick behind him from that
point on he is in all maroons and reds and
his heart is broken.
At one point he goes to a red wedding this
Italian/silver/black garish and he has the
Love Stinks scene and he freaks out and he
still has the broken heart of this ex and
starting to see Julia’s happiness again.
At the Bar mitzvah he still has the red jacket,
they bond over the little girl and he takes
off the red jacket because he finally looses
the other girl (the broken heart).
So that was done in a way where you didn’t
feel the director doing it but subconsciously
it’s there.
Other movies I like flying the camera around,
different angles and you just try to service
every scene the best you can.
In HOT AIR the indie I just did I had broken
the fourth wall and part of the goal of the
movie was to not pick sides and then at some
point, we’re not picking right being wrong
or left being wrong but I wanted everyone
in the audience to feel guilty for where we
are at and there’s a speech toward the end
of the movie where Steve has almost that NETWORK
moment where he breaks down and snaps on everyone
and the writer I said make sure we hit everyone
and Facebook and Instagram and phones and
he writes this brilliant speech and when I
shot it it was just sort of happening and
this is going to be great and jump cuts and
I’m like we’ve got to break to the fourth
wall and the very end of the movie Steve [Coogan]
looks down the lens and says “The American
Dream is dead and buried and you’re dancing
on its grave.”
And this was one of my…I’ve never broke
the fourth wall and I waited for the right
moment and it’s like you just try to direct
every scene the best you can and then it just
sort of happens sometimes where you feel like
that was pretty darn good!
Film Courage: Do you storyboard?
Frank: I shot listed and then if there are
visual effects or it gets complicated I storyboard.
It’s time constraints but I literally shotlist
and my goal is literally you shotlist the
movie in order because you read it and you
shotlist it because you read it and shotlist
it so you can evolve lens and do stuff.
Whenever I hear the director shows up that
day and decides what lenses unless you’re
shooting in order you’re not telling a real
story.
To me a movie is a vision from beginning to
end so I will in the beginning let’s start
on wide lenses so it’s close and intimate
but in the end…things like that you need
to progressively do so you need to plan it
ahead of time so you know you shoot day 31
- we are on the tight lenses, we’re not
on the wide or the color or the shirt should
be red not…so you have to plan all of that
stuff out in order.
That’s just discipline and sometimes I think
only 10 percent of the directors really do
the job like that and I think it shows.
People that are great are great for a reason.
It takes work.
The color thing came into play…my first
movie MURDERED INNOCENCE I literally had like
this guy had to be this guy and that guy,
the guy was just like a construction guy so
I didn’t have like a like a designer.
We were just using locations and I had seen
BILLY MADISON with Sandler and was like “Man,
the production design is amazing!”
And I’m like “I want that guy.”
And Perry Blake who has done almost all of
my movies because I was like that guy is great
we hit it off because the first movie we did
was WEDDING CRASHERS and I’m like “I want
to tell a story with colors not camera movements.”
So on every movie it’s all about like in
CLICK - he talked me into doing the movie
- he’s like “You get to create the future.”
And I’m like “Oh, yeah…wait the story
is great.”
One part of the future everything is angular
and next because we have a bunch of time jumps
the later part everything is rounding.
Even in just like storytelling color is in
HERE COMES THE BOOM with Kevin James he starts
as a horrible person who is just selfish,
it’s the winter and we made the color - we
pulled all the saturation and made it look
really cool.
It felt like THE FIGHTER and then as he blossoms
as a human being and then as a teacher and
starts teaching his kids and we get more and
more colorful and I start adding color, adding
color to the set and then we actually did
it so the seasons change too.
We timed the movie out so we’re shooting
an outdoor scene when the trees were blossoming
and then it ends in Vegas which was like full
spectacle.
So if you see reel one, it looks like THE
FIGHTER and you see the last reel you’re
like how are those the same movie but if you
progressively change your movie as you go
it will just happen without you being jarred
but yeah I love using color to tell a story
but that was from getting a production designer
and wardrobe too you start to realize in THE
WEDDING SINGER everybody is like color coded
(the same thing in The Ridiculous 6 each town
had a color palette.
It really gets tricky when there gets to be
hundreds of extras you really need a good
costume designer and you need a DP, costume
designer and producer designer all on the
same page.
That’s the thing that I love about doing
bigger budget movies you have just more control
over everything and it’s funny after I did
the indie I had the best time because I had
no one telling me what I should and shouldn’t
do.
It was literally my final cut and then I was
like man I’m really itching to do a big
movie again and I’m back now.
My next movie is going to be THE LEGEND OF
SINBAD but then I’m like but with that comes
all the politics too so it’s always a give
and take.
Film Courage: And the 1980’s was so colorful.
Even thinking back to [the TV show] DESIGNING
WOMEN and they all had the great outfits and
shoulder pads and it was so colorful.
Frank: And you know what is was for me - the
color palette in that movie - I think in the
eighties I think felt manmade (it was like
the 1950’s too).
I was like no 1970’s colors - no browns,
no green.
Everything was like fuchsia and purple and
electric blue because that’s my image of
the 1980’s.
All the sudden we’re making everything and
everybody’s haircuts were cut.
People didn’t have beards.
If they did it would be more trimmed.
Film Courage: There were colored stonewashed
jeans.
I had purple and turquoise.
Frank: Everything felt like people did stuff
to everything.
It didn’t just grow out of the ground.
Question for the viewers: What are the big
lessons you learned from this video?